c'est un show non tu veux que j'aille là
je sais pas les bons grains pour
maintien pour laurent launay vous bah ça
fait longtemps que c'est n'importe quoi
non je suis pas prêt moi j'ai pas mon
texte
quelqu'un mon texte dans le vent deux
solitudes personne ne répond tiens mais
il a eu une bonne est blanche et un
sweat blanc mais le mec est très très
fort logique merde voilà voilà voilà
mais qu'est ce qui fait de flying
dutchman il est perdu dans les options
ça c'est pas gagné à l'aller la belle
maquette en relatant ce mec est bronzée
la chute du dollar qui se voit dans sa
bannette blanche pour sweat blanc bonnet
de l'histoire ce qui porte à trois en
coupe et non bah voilà alors d'abord
taille mais je suis aussi doit on pas je
n'ai pas vu à temps sa lettre c'est
quatre cadres oui puisque se fait
reprendre de l'international français
même à barcelone
non je viens de retourner meilleure
transition en détournant au mode
transition en enflammant ghazi ses
mauvaises habitudes voilà ces mauvaises
habitudes donc la promesse d difficile à
réaliser à tenir du trou un enseignant
je suis en france je suis je suis je
fois encore excusé et a déjà fait pire
taux flamand sépare terrible vas-y pour
avancer
écoutez offrant 30 tournage merci à tous
pause déj